waouh c'est une super grande journée ça
fait des mois que je vous en parle ça
fait des mois que je vous parle des
smartphones avec des écrans pliables des
mois que je vous parle du galaxy x de
samsung des mois que je vous dis que
huawei ci mais aussi des mois que je
vous dis que les smartphones et les
écrans pliables c'est la prochaine
révolution des smartphones voilà
qu'aujourd'hui samsung a enfin présenté
enfin présenté à montrer en catimini un
peu en loucedé un peu cachée avec très
peu de lumière son tout premier
smartphone à écran pliable ça croyez moi
franchement c'est une révolution
[Musique]
il ya quelques jours je vous ai fait une
vidéo pour vous parler de riols qui a
présenté son smartphone c'est le
flextreme qui m'avait pas convaincu sur
le papier et je vous ai dit pourquoi ne
pas y aller bon si ça vous intéresse et
à la vidéo pour laisser un petit coup
d'oeil mais là par contre ça ne songe à
présenter son galaxy x alors on connaît
pas le nom exact il n'y a pas eu de deux
présentations officielles nous ont juste
sorti un proto lumières éteintes up
fermé ouvert voilà quoi il ressemble
dans la poche et on vous en dit pas plus
mais ce convoi est ce qui est super
intéressant c'est qu'il a été présenté à
la conférence des développeurs de
samsung donc ça veut dire que les
développeurs vont pouvoir commencer à
bosser dessus pour qu'au moment où il
sera présenté officiellement et qui sera
commercialisé pour le déjà des
applications complètement compatibles
avec ce nouveau smartphone et en plus ce
qui est génial c'est qu'ils ont fait
venir sur scène une personne qui bossent
si google android en disant que android
était 100% compatible avec les
smartphones à écran pliable
on voit que les smartphones à écran plat
vous vraiment être amené à se développer
on sait que huawei bosse dessus
également donc 2019 sera vraiment
l'année des smartphones à écran pliable
une nouvelle révolution qui arrive alors
on sait très bien que apple devrait y
arriver mais peut-être dans quelques
années quand le marché sera mûr pour
l'instant ça reste quand même un marché
de niche connais pas du tout les prix
des smartphones de leur gueule flex paye
et à 1300 et 1500 euros sur une marque
qu'il est globalement comme une personne
on sait pas du tout ce que va faire
samsung c'est parce que fera huawei là
dessus en tout cas ce qu'on veut c'est
que c'est vraiment génial parce qu'il
souffre comme un bouquin donc je prends
un bouquin alors je prends un beau gars
continuent de look sur lequel je bosse
lorsqu'il est fermé vous avez un petit
écran ici de jeunes j'imagine que ce
sera un écran de peut-être 5 pouces et
quelques on sait pas trop qui sera
vraiment utilisable en version
smartphone ça c'est un type au grand
sens pas si grand que ça donc vous
pourrez utiliser votre smartphone vos
sms gérer rapidement téléphoner avec
sans aucun problème comme ce que j'ai
toujours les gros smartphone mais
lorsque vous l'ouvrez vous avez un écran
de 7,3 pousse pas moins poids pas moins
pas plus c'est du super amoled l'écran
s'appelle c'est la fille
if infiniti infiniti a les infiniti flex
display alors il ya eu tout un boulot
qui a été fait pour pouvoir le plier ce
qu'ont publié plus de cent mille fois
des centaines de milliers de fois n'a
pas de chiffres exacts pour ça on
attendra la présentation officielle mais
en tout cas on voit un petit peu le
principe voir à quoi il ressemble et ça
c'est vraiment génial parce que ça fait
des mois une fois de plus je suis
passionné ça fait des mois que je vous
en parlais que je vous dis effectivement
le smartphone à écran prière on sait pas
s'il va se plier comme de ce qu'on avait
sur les anciens smartphones un peu comme
un petit canard ou alors comme un
bouquin au final c'est l'option bouquin
qui a été retenu on sait qu'il y avait
vraiment des hésitations entre les deux
la pompe ou sofia s'est tranché
il s'ouvrira un peu comme un bouquin
pour avoir en fait deux résultats 1re
usages c'est un smartphone classique
deuxième usage souffre c'est une
tablette c'est une vraie tablette
donc on voit que la révolution elle se
fait sur des smartphones hybride
on n'est plus sûr du smartphone ondées
sur un produit hybride smartphone
tablette que vous pouvez utiliser des
deux manières alors ça c'est vraiment
bien point négatif maintenant c'est
l'épaisseur de la bête forcément les
écrans sont très très forts ils ont été
vraiment miniaturisés pour être
extrêmement fins par contre le rendu
final est quand même assez épais
forcément il ya pas mal de composants
dans c'est un petit peu compliqué faire
un truc hyper fin alors on imagine que
dans les années à venir les évolutions
se faisant ça va venir de plus en plus
petit des composants toujours plus
miniaturisés plus de performances plus
de puissance et une partie écran
vraiment optimisé donc ça va avoir un
petit peu on n'est qu'au début donc
d'ici quelques années ce sera amené à
évoluer en tout cas c'est vraiment
vraiment mais vraiment passionnant parce
que une fois qu'il est ouvert on se dit
ok c'est cool un grand écran mais qu'est
ce que je veux faire avec un écran de
7,3 pouces il faut vraiment réfléchir à
de nouveaux usages c'est à dire que
lorsqu'il ouvert vous allez avoir du
multitâche mais du vrai
multitâche affiché sur un seul et même
écran imaginez sur une colonne vous avez
une vidéo vous regardez une vidéo
youtube fait que ce que vous voulez à
côté vous avez messenger vous pouvez
répondre à quelqu'un en même temps vous
rendez votre vidéo oui ok je regarde ça
c'est génial patron ce mois ci et ça et
en même temps maintien j'aime sa
dentelle dans la série dans le film je
fais une petite recherche en dessous
troisième partie de l'écran donc une
partie de l'écran pour garder votre
vidéo la deuxième partie pour en parler
avec vos potes en direct et la troisième
partie enfin de recherches
complémentaires par rapport à ce que
vous regardez on peut l'imaginer sur du
loisir on peut l'imaginer sur du pro /
du travail sur la vidéo compte sur pas
mal de choses et c'est un outil qui ira
très bien aussi bien aux particuliers
qu'aux professionnels dont des usages y
en avoir plein comme ce qu'on peut avoir
aujourd'hui sur une tablette c'est
vraiment prometteur on ne sait
absolument pas où seront les caméras il
nage il fera une caméra fermé sur la
partie smartphone en egypte aura
d'autres caméras à l'intérieur lorsque
vous allez l'utiliser de manière pas mal
de choses
je prends ça va être vraiment très très
intéressant extrêmement passionnant
d'autant plus que je voulais dit le
galaxy s 10 qui sera présentée début
d'année devrait avoir une caméra soit
sous l'écran en tout cas soit
extrêmement bien intégré avec un petit
rôle petit découpe donc au pouvoir
trouver ça également de sur ce
smartphone dont on connaît toujours pas
le nom donc on va dire le galaxy x on en
restait là dessus en tout cas et c'est
vraiment vraiment passionnant un
smartphone qui sera présentée du coup
début 2019
là tout le monde bosse dessus les
développeurs vont bosser dessus de
prendre pleins d'applications
compatibles à sa sortie croyez-moi début
2019 on va rester chaud patate on va
suivre ça de très très près donc vous
invite à faire une seule chose c'est à
vous abonner au restez connectés j'irai
voir tout ça du côté de las vegas du
goûter du mwc on ira au cs on ira à
barcelone et on regardera au final si on
arrive à le voir si on peut le prendre
en main qui on peut le découvrir il voir
un petit peu tout ce qui se trame
parce que croyez moi des smartphones à
écran pliable ne pas en avoir plein ou
hawaï va se dépêcher de sortir sa copie
et plein d'autres constructeurs
d'arrière vont s'y mettre
donc ça s'apprend moyens dès 2019
vraiment passionnante
alors pour l'instant on n'a pas de nom
on n'a pas de prix on n'a pas de date on
n'a rien on a juste vu en tout cas ce
qu'on a vu c'est hyper alléchant dites
moi ce que vous en pensez qu est ce que
vous en pensez
est ce que vous êtes plutôt content est
ce que vous êtes plutôt déçu est-ce que
vous aurez ferait que ce soit un petit
peu dans l'autre sens vous marquez tout
ça on reste connectés puis bien sûr on
en reparlera trouve ça vraiment génial
et ce soir je sois vous tourne le soir
juste après la confession ou diffuse
deux
matane ont tout de suite quand vous
regardez je suis hyper enthousiaste vous
marquez tout ça on n'a pas merci à vous
soit il s'agit dans as
à bientôt tous
[Musique]